oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission qu'il ne faut
absolument pas manquer si vous êtes un
amoureux du sport local on est le
mercredi à 19 juin et les épreuves du
bac où commencer je vous propose donc
une présentation très studieuse de nos
chroniqueurs on commence à ma droite
musique7 et l'élève toujours dissiper au
fond de la classe au lycée celui qui
aimait parler avec les copains et
draguer les filles enfin qui essayait le
capitaine yann dujarrier pistard au club
de vélizy 78 est avec nous michael vous
connaissez trop bien c'est exactement
non pas mot pour mot donc rien à
rajouter
non non c'était ça après j'ai alors il
est sérieux peut mieux faire
voilà une des appréhensions que j'avais
souvent et j'ai eu aussi et les fantômes
vous êtes bien présenter ce bateau pour
l'émission on passe de l'autre côté un
musique elle vient tout juste de sortir
du lycée elle était à la fois studieuse
et bavarde mais à l'arrivée toujours
avoir de super note notre petite
nouvelle
véronique chaplin fondatrice du tiebreak
est avec nous et coach mental également
oui comment avez-vous super en forme
même chose que pour yann c'est à peu
près vous la description non pas du tout
je trouve qu'il était une ex très
studieuse excellente élève première de
la classe
voilà tout à fait dans un peu bavarde
c'est arrivé sur le tard
cette émission en tout cas on passe de
l'autre côté musique il était sage comme
une image en classe ces professeurs
l'adoré c'est est le chouchou mais avec
le temps il sait dévergondée pour
devenir dans cette émission la légende
le mythe notre super chroniqueur coach
jean miss ex-entraîneur de plaisir est
avec nous bonsoir vous êtes sage
aujourd'hui et c'est toujours
j'ai toujours été très sage très
studieux sous huy aussi 8 août
joueur est toujours le premier jamais
raté un court j'ai excellé
bon rien à dire rien à dire absolument
rien on termine de l'autre côté musique
il sait chez parfois les cours pour
aller chevauchée dans la campagne avec
ses chevaux mais il n'oubliait pas
d'avoir de très bonnes notes à l'école
notre oreille dinoire raul contre
l'autre et le plaisir est avec nous
bonjour michael quand allez-vous raul
parfait pareil où vous alliez vous
balader un peu à la carte
pour moi les bandes incarne n'était pas
trop fait pour moi donc vous avez eu
votre bac quand même oui c'est déjà ça
c'est pénible mans alors avant passer au
thème de l'émission armo de football
messi vient de signer à dijon vous
m'avez bien entendu ryan mais 6 12 ans
jeune attaquant licencié au fc
versailles 78 intégré le centre de
formation du club
il a été repéré en février dernier par
les recruteurs du club qui évolue en
ligue 1 l'ue souhaite évidemment d'avoir
la même carrière que l'argentin du fc
barcelone et de remporter cinq ballons
d'or dans le futur une réaction pour toi
cette table yann beau courage
bon courage je l' ai déjà dit sur ce
plateau
le parcours pour devenir un grand
champion et alors là quand on parle de
personnes comme messi c'est vraiment le
terme qu'il faut qu'il faut employer et
donc le parcours est très très long et
très compliqué je m'aide beaucoup
d'embûches faut éviter les blessures
faux faux faux avoir un peu de chance
aussi et donc voilà il est sûr qu'on va
dire qu'il est sur de bons rails mais
mais voilà c'est loin d'être terminé et
il faut avoir un gros gros mental
mais donc faut rien laisser au hasard je
pense que
aujourd'hui les centres de formation la
taxe beaucoup là dessus il faut pas
oublier justement le côté études parce
que parce que ben à n'importe quel
moment une carrière sportive je ne peux
pas juste dire de footballeur mais une
carrière sportive peut s'arrêter à
n'importe quel moment sur sur un coude
sur un coup du sort et donc
donc voilà donc bonne chance à lui bien
sûr qu'on puisse être le meilleur et qui
puisse représenter les yvelines plus
tard plus tard voilà simplement qu'il
euvrard l'unc en six ans mais bien sûr
cessé et le politique oui ça peut aller
vite mais bon voilà c'est son des années
très importante et l'adolescence et est
loin d'être une période facile pour les
pour les pour les pour les jeunes donc
donc voilà c'est bon courage
véronique sony mais si ça va pas lui
porter préjudice
juste en non non non non non non il va
faire sa personnalité il va se faire un
prénom
là ces chaussées qui justement qu'il
reste lui même qu'il ait sa propre
identité avec un joli nom au contraire
qu'il peut lui porter chance
et puis qui n'oublie pas de travail et
de mental à côté des débuts du physique
des études
voilà mentalement qui ce qui se renforce
au que quoi qu'il arrive il est à bella
mia raul un nom comme celui là ça vous
évoque quoi je pense que là on parle de
choses sérieuses ont dans le sport de
haut niveau il ya la croisée des chemins
je pense que un prénom est un facteur
vraiment négligeable par rapport à
l'importance des choix qui les affaires
du genre ok adoré ce genre d'info c'est
bien le gamin à 12 il a 12 ans il ya de
la vie il faut aussi qu'il soit très
très bien encadré voilà parce que c'est
un enfant de 12 ans ne sera pas
l'handicaper lui mettre trop de pression
bah j'espère qu'il n'a pas la pression à
12 ans parce que ce serait regrettable
s'il a déjà la pression
à cet âge là bas il serait trop dur pour
lui il les années vont être longs mais
après un mba pea saison était déjà en
ligue des champions oui c'est bien mais
ces exceptions quand il y en a
tous les combien donc on lui souhaite à
lui aussi mais bon c'est un gamin
donc il faut qu'ils soient bien encadrés
pour ce qui reste bien sur terre julian
pour tous les sports et pour tout l'est
pour tous les jeunes et puis même
d'ailleurs mais même quand on est adulte
le sport doit rester le leitmotiv du
sport ça doit rester un plaisir
ça ne peut pas être une contrainte vous
ne pouvez pas donner le meilleur de vous
si si vous allez à l'entraînement sous
là si ça vous emmerde d'aller à
l'entraînement tout simplement il faut
que il faut que ça reste il faut que ça
reste un plaisir
même quand on va se déchirer même quand
on va se faire mal sur des séances
d'entraînement il faut qu' il faut qu'on
sache pourquoi
et à partir de là le travail sera plus
facile alors nous allons maintenant
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de bmx
les français emporté trois médailles
lors d'une manche de coupe du monde qui
s'est déroulée au stadium de st quentin
en yvelines nous font également un coup
de projecteur sur le baseball les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux ont
terminé troisièmes de la coupe d'europe
en république tchèque
nous avons de développer ces thèmes on a
parlé de golf
[Musique]
on commence donc par du golfe est une
très bonne nouvelle
elle concerne la ryder cup 2018 d'après
une étude commandée par les
organisateurs dont la fédération
française la dernière édition qui s'est
déroulée au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines en septembre dernier
aurait boosté l'activité économique de
la france à hauteur de 235 millions
d'euros pour une semaine de compétition
les revenus concerne à la fois les
restaurants les hôtels les transports
une première réussie pour une ryder cup
sur le sol français
on écoute le dtn de la fédération
française et christophe muniesa est liée
au succès de l'événement en délit
également à 4,8 enfin dans d'un point de
vue mais qui a dit que en termes
d'attractivité du grand public et fait
évidemment notre action va faire un
petit tour de table ce chiffre vous
surprend-il
jean oui oui ben oui parce que c'est
quand même énorme
après il est certain que c'était
vraiment une manifestation très réussie
l'envergure énorme avec des retombées
maintenant qu'on arrive à chiffrer mais
c'est quand même impressionnant parce
que juste pour me semble que on était on
était sûr peut-être même pas la moitié
avant sur la dernière ryder cup alors
dernière ryder cup avait gêné l'heure
est donc à gleneagles en écosse cdt en
2014 avait généré 119 millions d'euros
mais ce qui semblait pas ce que je
voulais pour être sûr mais il savait
bien qu'on était autour de 5 millions
donc là c'est plus du double de 119 238
235 le double donc bien sûr que c'est
énorme c'est un chiffre énorme
ensuite j'ai entendu dire dans les
coulisses que tous les bénéfices n'avait
pas sur le territoire français je laisse
et véronique nouragues nous approfondir
cette ce débat mais pour moi pour moi
c'est 238 et c'est quand même sur le sol
phrasé et dans les yvelines que cette
manifestation s'est déroulée donc
cocorico véronique vous avez été
interpellé par l'argent oui non mais
j'en à raison moi j étais puisque
chipeau c'est donc j'ai pu voir cet
engouement pour la première fois de ma
vie moi qui travaille dans le milieu du
golf aussi j'ai trouvé que c'était une
vraie grande belle fête populaire est
une organisation parfaite
une masse de gens une
énorme ambiance en revanche c'est vrai
que sur ce chiffre là il ya beaucoup de
bénéfices qui sont qui ont été pour les
organisateurs les anglais tous les
vendeurs étaient marque anglo saxon
néanmoins donc bon bah ça si on organise
une prochaine ryder cup peut-être plus
voilà arrivé maintenant qu'on a prouvé
qu'on pouvait accueillir grandement et
avoir un peu plus d'autonomie
la france mais en revanche l'image de la
france de paris de versailles des
yvelines
voilà a été a été vraiment très très
valorisé raul
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais moi
c'est un chiffre qui me surprend pas
tant que ça parce que d'abord une la
france est un pays de golfeurs ensuite
on savait que cet événement elle est
allée bénéficié d'une grosse couverture
médiatique parce qu'il y avait beaucoup
de bruit qui étaient générés par le le
retour de tiger woods également plein de
plein de choses au niveau de
l'organisation aussi qu'ils faisaient je
pense que le succès de cet événement
était était prévisible
donc c'était la première fois qu'il y
avait 270 mille personnes
bien sûr un grise était attendu c'est
perçu durant toute la compétition
version je crois que ce chiffre était à
attendre et bravo bravo 2
attention s'il est question de refaire
une édition attention à ce que la barre
a été placée très haute
je suis monté sur la question après la
question est ce que les chambres d'hôtel
sont pas deux fois plus cher en france
qu'en écosse et donc du coup
automatiquement ça fait deux fois de
plus que les enfants soient gleneagles
c'était quand même dans la campagne
écossaise pour venir sur votre
interrogation s'était jusque là il était
juste une boutade bien sûr je ne pense
pas que ce soit lié à ça sent que le
goliath à ma classe voilà c'était plutôt
lié un vrai engouement et à
voilà simplement le fait qu ait plus de
monde qui est plus venir et les moyens
qui ont été mis en place aussi pour les
accueillir parce que cette tribune
elle était magnifique et elle a été
pleine non-stop pendant pendant trop
c'est trop quatre journées à la ryder
cup ce n'est même plus bonjour trois
jours voilà donc pas de compétition mais
5,5 toujours sur l'ensemble de jeu
devait donc voilà c'est qu'on sait que
la france on est capable d'organiser en
est capable d'accueillir on a on a tous
toutes les infrastructures pour pour
pour réaliser ces gros événement
ben oui maintenant on va passer à la
question suivante parce que parce que
ouais bien sûr qu'il faut il faut il
faut que ça sorte une petite précision
220 mille nuits d'hôtel ont été
réservées aux alentours du golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines pendant la
compétition est un petit peu avant aussi
ma grosse mama grosses craintes étaient
c'était l'accessibilité au golf national
parce que quand quand je vois
régulièrement enfin tous les ans quand
ils organisent le le peuple de france
ben voilà on réquisitionne quelques
parkings autour de quelques chants
autour du autour du golf pour pouvoir
garer tout le monde est là c'est vrai
que tout a été fait pour que les
navettes et les navets devenait très
loin j'avais moi je me souviens avoir vu
des navets devenir de saclay donc des
sacs les on pouvait commencer à se garer
et ensuite venir en transports s'était
c'était cadré les gens se garaient à
satory et c'est pareil c'était des
navettes qui vous voilà tout a été très
très bien très très bien géré et là
dessus pour éviter d'être au
d'engorgement au bord dû au bord du
golfe nationale donc à un grand chapeau
pour pour tout cet organisme cette
orchestration justement la question sur
ce thème
est-ce qu'il faut réorganiser une ryder
cup ici à saint quentin en yvelines
oui ou non vous est unanime à vous êtes
partagés
et oui je pense qu'on a les bonnes
choses qu'on a les arguments pour moi
c'est que je crois que c'était une toute
première que beaucoup de facteurs
étaient en faveur de l'événement et que
est ce qu'il faut le réorganiser oui
parce qu'on l'a on a démontré qu'on
avait la capacité à le faire de la
meilleure des manières mais s'attendre
aux mêmes bénéfices et aux mêmes
retombées économiques
je ne suis pas sûr voilà pourquoi je
mettais un petit bémol
voilà pourquoi j'avais j'ai donné une
réponse avait à deux facettes vous vers
hollywood convaincu à 100 % à 200 % % à
200 % parce que moi vous savez ces
sportifs de haut niveau quand vous voyez
quelqu'un qui est quand même de
notoriété comme yannick noah qui une
semaine avant ce vous aime et une joie
immense de jouer le pro-am avant la
ryder cup s'est entraîné avec peur etc
des gens des footballeurs connus qui du
cameroun m'ont demandé des places deux
ou trois mois avant et c'est là ils ont
vu que cette extraordinaire il ya des
talents qu'on dit si j'avais su donc moi
à fond parce qu'il ya une vraie
consonance internationale et la ryder
cup dans le monde entier c'est la ryder
cup au delà des médias ils sont là etc
mais c'est vraiment l'événement 90 pays
étaient représentés dans les indicateurs
oui oui tout à fait donc
et puis d'un milliard de personnes ont
regardé à la compétition un événement
exceptionnel exceptionnelle à refaire
absolument si on peut en tout cas la
fédération française n'exclut pas
d'organiser dans les prochaines années
une nouvelle ryder cup on écoute
christophe muniesa
pour ce qui est de la ryder cup il ya un
processus de candidature et on fait pour
être tout à fait par celui ci il était
long et complexe et que la planète la
prochaine fenêtre de tir se fera pas
avant 2026 voire 2030
donc oui on est très clairement motivé
pour candidater de doro à l'accueil que
ce type de compétition donc si on
comprend bien la fédération française
envisage vraiment d'organiser cette
nouvelle ryder cup 2026 2030
ça vous va j'en sais très bien qu'ils
n'ont pas le choix ils s'attablent
bonbons la sphère avoir nos gulf air
après faut attendre non attendant 26,37
très bien le plus tôt plus tôt possible
justement parce qu'il y aura encore dans
les mémoires cette organisation qui a
été qu un magnifique et je rejoins
véronique sur l'engouement est certaine
certaines personnes sont des catégories
de personnes qui qui étaient attentistes
sur cet événement et qui à mon avis la
prochaine fois
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas trop d'accord
mon ami qui lui et lui lui enlever ça
marchera pas moi je pense avoir sera
encore mieux pour mieux parce qu'il
avait quand même beaucoup de beaucoup de
gens qui étaient attentistes après les
premières fois marche toujours mieux non
j'ai vu cet effet là valderrama par
exemple en espagne en 1997
on était à peu près sur le même cas de
figure c'était la première ryder cup qui
étaient organisées en dehors de la
grande bretagne
ayez vu cet engouement la égal avec
moins de retombées économiques ou les
moyens de savoir faire une phrase on a
vraiment le savoir faire et on a
vraiment les installations pour un cadre
magnifique quand même il faut savoir
qu'un que le national et les alentours
parce que c'est ça aussi
selon pour vous parler de la de l'ecosse
tout à l'heure bon entre la pampa plein
milieu de la forêt entre trois vachers
et de dinosaures encore aller faire le
golf ça aide à voir avec lui en cours et
le national avec tout ce qu'il ya autour
tout ce que les yvelines procure ne
serait-ce que même en tourisme donc les
gens qui viennent en intensité notamment
guèye et voilà non mais forcément donc
il ya un cadre qui est qui et qui est
privilégiée est magnifique avec le
savoir-faire à + moi je suis persuadé
que ça va qu'on va exploser les
compteurs si on revenait à le faire et
le plus tôt sera le même justement pour
que dans les mémoires on se souvient
encore de cette organisation l'an
dernier d'accord en 2026 ben pour moi si
on leur a pas au moins avant 20 ans 20
ans minimum avant que la ryder cup rôle
alors la ryder cup est organisée je le
rappelle tous les deux ans une fois aux
états unis et une autre fois à la en
europe et chasse cas par exemple dans le
minnesota a réalisé la ryder cup en 2016
et vale a réorganisé en 2028
donc c'est possible mais c'est le seul
golf la première fois c'est la première
fois qu'il ya un golf qu'il organisera
deux fois donc hélas en effet donc ils
ont 12 ans il y aura 12 entre entre
chaque
entre les deux organisations et donc
c'est alors en effet donc du coup si on
part sur 12 ans pourquoi pas le refaire
en 2030
ouais ce serait peut-être la meilleure
faire de tiers mais on pourra pas
l'avoir c'est impossible c'est
impossible de l'impossible de véronique
2026 tout est possible moi je
préférerais 2026 parce que parce que je
suis persuadé que la deuxième édition
effectivement va exploser les compteurs
et puis et puis pour nous c'est
important parce que tous ces étrangers
qui reviennent avec très belles images
des yvelines a effectivement autour du
parc fait rapidement une 26 au public on
organise déjà les jeux olympiques en
2024 et dont mary mais on pourra pas
enchaîner on pourra pas enchaîner les on
pourra pas enchaîner les événements
c'est impossible
justement donc le golf national
accueillera les jo de 2024 au golf
national et les championnats du monde
juniors en 2023 et sans oublier l'open
de france qui sera organisée bien sûr
tous les ans sur le golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
on va maintenant parler rugby allier
sport et solidarité c'était l'objectif
du tournoi 7 de coeur qui s'est déroulé
à versailles le week-end du 15 juin
pour cette huitième édition une
trentaine d'équipés étaient présentes au
stade de porchefontaine pour participer
à des rencontres de rugby à 7
il y avait notamment des joueurs venus
de toute la france mais aussi
d'angleterre ou de chine on écoute des
habitués du tournoi nous ça fait ça fait
pas mal d'années compte on est là on est
à versailles et
et à chaque fois c'est toujours un
plaisir de jouer ici le voir le niveau
un peu et de surtout de participer à une
asso caritative eux deux pour tous ces
gens là et pour le rugby en plus que
c'est un tournoi qui est très relevé
sportivement et en même temps le
caritatif sais c'est la cerise sur le
gâteau c'est le fait de pouvoir jouer au
rugby et faire maintenant une bonne
action cet événement a permis de
récolter 90 mille euros cette année le
ton assez de coeur a soutenu cinq
associations dont celle de l'ancien
international français patrice le gélat
gisci vous connaissez ou pas jean vous
avez au monde du rugby
oui bien sûr c'est connu quand même un
tournoi qui a lieu tous les 1 et fait
l'année dernière il était fou aussi à
versailles d'ailleurs lancé je sais bien
plus il a fait super beau
c'est dans un bon état d'esprit c'est un
tournant à 7 et même du 5 1 d'ailleurs
assez tout 20 singles
ouais c'était un peu les deux bien va
s'imposer non là c'est bien c'est puis
bon là c'est trop du caritatif donc en
allier allier le sport avec le caritatif
c'est toujours c'est toujours très
intéressant les déjà participé en tant
que joueur non en plein jour je joue
plus depuis longtemps c'est tentant de
rejoindre un cadrage et des joueurs oui
j'ai des joueurs qu'il le faut qu'ils
ont fait l'an dernier
sam problème ils l'ont fait avec plaisir
ils l'ont fait ils l'ont fait avec gifi
sur les dettes alors on voit de plus en
plus en tout cas d'action de ce type la
question sur ce thème est ce que c'est
le rôle du sport d'aider des
associations
oui ou non vous votez vous êtes partagés
leur niveau est partagée il ya vous êtes
partage également en faire un petit duel
véronique pourquoi vous êtes partagés
pour moi le sport est un magnifique
support pour les associations moi en
tant que présidente d'association j'ai
toujours utilisé supporter pourquoi
parce que les sportifs ont toujours une
grande âme d'enfant ils sont très
généreux de la utiliser le support voilà
le caritatif peut utiliser n'importe
quel support mai
la musique par exemple ça peut être la
musique ça peut être des tas de choses
ce qu'il ya c'est que c'est vrai que le
sport est rassembleur au delà des
différences donc je pense que c'est un
c'est un bon moyen mais en tant que
support voilà bien mais je suis mitigé
parce que il faut pas que ça tombe dans
la facilité non plus on fait un ont fait
du sport pour pouvoir faire du caritatif
parce que c'est facile d'en lundi du
sport je pense qu'il faut simplement
pour pouvoir faire j'ai le caritatif
avoir la bonne idée
et à partir de là les gens vont les gens
vont des gens vont suivre si vous avez
le bon le bon support et que vous avez
deux et vous mettez de l'autre côté le
bon quelque chose qui va plaire aux gens
voilà faut avoir la bonne idée
voilà faut pas devenir faut pas que ce
faux pas qu'il faut pas que cela rentre
dans la facilité et 7 viennent et ça
devient des automatismes le sport c'est
avant tout c'est avant tout une école et
et d'éducation maintenant oui il permet
de passer des messages et de et donc du
coup de servir à cela mais faut pas que
ce soit
faut pas que ce soit trop trop trop
présent non plus rôle tu faisais
beaucoup de mal à trouver de l'argent
pour faire vivre le sport raul vous avez
été convaincu par bien sûr mon propos va
se rapprocher un petit peu de celui de
véronique à savoir que le sport pour moi
est une des plateformes entre guillemets
les moins politisées donc les plus
saines pour véhiculer ce type ce type
ce type d'événement les oeuvres
caritatives et puis parce que les
sportifs je pense sont les plus les plus
concernés par ces notions qui plaisait
dans le sport collectif par ces notions
de partage et de don un sportif qu'ils
soient amateurs ou aux loisirs aux mêmes
professionnels fait beaucoup de dons
fait beaucoup de concessions
donc je crois que c'est le sait le
meilleur acteur à utiliser pour ce genre
de ce genre de phénomène voilà le genre
mathématiques aux bonbons n'utilise plus
de rugby on utilise le rugby qui est un
sport car quelqu'un de belles valeurs
le sport collectif excellent excellence
au niveau des valeurs bien également le
golf par exemple véronique pour
énormément d'événements d'âge
oui je tendais alors je suis assez
d'accord sur l'esprit du sportif
collectif mais moi j'ai pratiqué le
marathon du tennis par exemple des
sports individuels et justement on est
content de retrouver là des événements
collectifs de corps aux notes sport ça
c'est très important pays et je vois
dans mes événements que les tennismans
les sportifs individuels sont contents
et jouent le jeu à fond parce que
justement il se retrouve en collectif et
ça ça n'a pas de prix mais dans le tibre
est par exemple vous organiser des
tournois en double en fait
alors voilà c'est toujours par équipes
tout et par équipes que ça soit les les
multisports où le gall c'est un titre
par équipes et donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de jouer les quatre balles
meilleure balle avec la stratégie la
tactique que tout le monde et est
impliqué donc parce qu'en individuel
oui tout à fait dont claude bille
rejoignez nous a dit ceci veut dire on a
le tour de france
et est adepte de mètres de mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque qui les accompagnent
et qu'ils aident beaucoup et tous les
ans il ya une étape qui est parcouru par
par des célébrités pour vous raconter
des fonds pour cette association qui qui
est des jeunes avec des défaillances des
défaillances cardiaques qui vient de se
faire opérer en france ça ne coûte rien
ils viennent en famille d'accueil etc
c'est une série très s'est décidé très
beau visage mais voilà moi je réagirai
sur damon il faut pas que ce soit
persuadé systématique voilà parce que
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les grands
sportifs sont énormément sollicités et
du coup ces sept bien c'est déjà
difficile il faut plus ou pas pour vous
jean plus plus de quoi plus d'événements
de ce type ont il y en a déjà pas mal et
puis attention il faut il ne faut pas
non plus on le dit depuis tout à l'heure
sur ce plateau faut pas non plus que
ça prenne sur le sportif
parce que tous ces joueurs là on parle
du set de coeur tous ces sportifs tous
ces joueurs là ont leur championnat
respectif dans leurs différents clubs et
que c'est quand même le propre et la
base de leur sport dans leur club mais
ils sont ils sont faits pour ça avant
tout la c1 2 campus c'est une oeuvre
caritative
et puis un bon moment de deux de
convivialité et plus si affinités donc
d'accord mais il faut pas non plus trop
juin avec modération
la troisième la passion toujours
toujours avec modération est exagérée
par de l'eau deux jours de donc là mais
il faut pas non plus trop exagérer ce
que didier jan faut pas non plus que ce
soit c'est trop systématique et que ça
engendre un petit peu trop de de
multiplication de ce genre d'événement
parce qu'on se disait ça marche pour le
caritatif donc on va me faire un peu
plus non faut faire attention
là c'est quand même particulier ça
existe depuis c'est certainement donc la
ccc différentes ne faut pas non plus que
ce soit trop dans la vue on va passer
maintenant notre rubrique résultats et
on continue par du bmx
[Musique]
en bmx donc une manche de coupe du monde
de bmx s'est tenue au stadium de st
quentin en yvelines les 8 et 9 juin
dernier plus de 12000 à personnes ont
assisté à l'événement et ont pu voir
trois médailles françaises de médailles
de joris daudet qui termine 3e et 2e et
surtout la victoire de manon un
valentine on écoute la réaction de la
champions les publics français était là
à crier encore et encore et je me suis
dit il faut que j'ai beau geste et j'ai
poussé dans les bols s'est passé c'est
juste incroyable d'avoir gagné ici les
prochaines manches de la coupe du monde
se dérouleront les 14 et 15 septembre
aux états unis la question sur ce thème
peut-on se satisfaire de ce résultat
je rappelle qu'il y avait à neuf pilotes
français parmi les 250 sportifs présents
oui ou non fait partager jantes on est
ok pourquoi vous êtes passager
je suis partagé parce que sportivement
on ne peut pas se satisfaire de 2 3
médailles or il faut toujours viser le
plus alors certes c'est sûr c'est une
belle performance on va dire un titre et
une médaille d'argent mais elle repose
sur quatre courses c'est ça alors 12
médailles 12 médailles
certes c'est une belle performance je
dis je le répète ne peut pas se
satisfaire
sinon nous arrêter là on dit c'est bon
on l'a on a eu trois médailles
un titre et puis c'est bien on s'arrête
là non il faut qu on ne peut pas se
satisfaire de ça la question était bien
de se satisfaire
je dis non faut toujours viser plus haut
sinon mes progrès sport
raul alors vous vous êtes plutôt
satisfait oui parce que il ya douze
médailles
on en en touche on en touche le web dans
tous le quart à nous tout seul je sais
pas s'il ya d'ailleurs un pays qui a
fait mieux au temps
je n'ai pas c'est ça qui dès les pays
pas les pays bas sont à peu près à trois
ou quatre médailles or en diamants
voilà donc le en rajoutent 7 à domicile
je peux qu'être d'accord avec jean
puisque le la complaisance et la
satisfaction n'est pas n'est pas n'est
pas quelque chose d'à entretenir dans le
sport de haut niveau ça je suis d'accord
maintenant il faut qu'il faut aussi
savoir quand même se se contentés des
performances pour le pour le moral
positive et la spirale positive du sport
français
donc bon je salue la performance mais
effectivement il n'est pas question de
se reposer sur ses lauriers
chers amis vient du jeu vous sang chaud
bouillant sur ce nom je suis pas non je
suis pas chaud bouillant mais c'est faux
on sait tous que le bmx est un sport a
pas dire aléatoire mais il ya il faut
une part de chance un gain de versets
requis qui tourne dans un virage juste
devant vous et voilà la compétition est
finie et si ça se déroule en finale ben
voilà il ya vraiment zéro point de se
rattraper j'ai quand même noter ces
quatre français en finale quatre
français 6-4 sur lui de sa finale de
l'ohl et sandy joris daudet romain
mahieu jérémy rencurel et romain mallet
il termine 3e 4e 5e et 6e dont trois sur
trois sur quatre sur huit est la même
chose de dimanche quatre filles et
quatre fissures 8 en finale
chose qui ne s'était pas produite depuis
x années les filles et j'ai une question
4 sur vite ne pouvait pas s'arrêter pour
faire tomber tout le monde dans les
trois premiers et sur quatre
je sais c'est que les valeurs du rugby
elles sont où mais la main sur quatre
est simplifié à quito mais devant les
autres et que shell est appelée 3 et
finissait roue libre 1er 2e 3e étaient
des stratégies des faux accent mise en
place j'aurais fait mon sort genre midi
on peut bien sûr qu'il faut être
satisfait et et puis bon à joris daudet
qui reste à son niveau qui est quand
même une fois deuxième une fois
troisième juillet sur deux jours de
compétition paparazzi ça se joue à des
détails vous avez vu l'arrivée
vous avez vu l'arrivée de la finale avec
avec manon elles sont trois sur la même
ligne
ça se jouera une demi roue devant la
gagne ça joue sur joan miró admis vélo
sur un sur un parcours sur un parcours
garder regarder voilà on voit très bien
elles sont elles sont les unes à côté
des autres
alors que sur les manches qualificatives
ça joue beaucoup plus tôt ccc toujours
fini beaucoup la voilà sur la finale
bain les des huit les usa des
adversaires sont à moins de 10 mètres à
l'arrivée donc ça veut dire que le
niveau est hyper hyper dense c'est la
silly stuff et 400 m 1 je précise que
c'est très compliqué de pouvoir sortir
son épingle du jeu
ça joue à dd mm et donc voilà on a eu
une belle victoire on a un deux podiums
pour joris de sahin faudel nous sommes
dix ans pauline au dimanche peut
difficilement faire mieux bien sûr que
ça aurait été top qui soit qu' un petit
doublé away à 7,7 ce finish il est il et
il est génial mais la quatrième elle est
tout juste tout juste derrière non c'est
la vie c'est d'enchaîner avec ça
toujours à quelques millimètres
donc en tant que sportif on veut
toujours plus et mieux
je rejoins jean évidemment mais un
moment où ça vous roulez victoire là
c'est la coach qui parle
il faut savoir apprécier et savourer
remercier féliciter pour mieux repartir
et encore plus haut voilà après ce que
vous pensez que joris daudet a bien vécu
son sa manche de coupe du monde en
finissant 2e et 3e
oui oui je suis d'accord avec toi mais
kate 2e 3e tu te situes tu as toujours
les boules de ne pas être premier c'est
une coupe du monde c'est pas un
championnat du monde c'est pas quelque
chose à lille est 2e de la coupe du
monde a une grosse claque aux différents
sur une coupe du monde c'est que on est
là pour marquer des points et l'objectif
c'est le classement général à la fin de
la saison sur un championnat du monde
c'est la course d'un jour est en effet
une fois que le premier sur une coupe du
monde il faut marquer le plus de points
font marquer le plus de points il faut
être régulier il faut être régulier
voilà si la régularité qui va payer
de leurs résultats et après demande
d'alain questions sur cette thématique
est ce que c'est de bonne augure pour
les jeux olympiques en sachant que cette
manche de coupe du monde est déjà dans
le programme d'accession pour les jeux
sont ils faits c'était génial
c'est du même niveau c'est du même
acabit
le champion en titre de champion
olympique était la championne olympique
devait être là aussi enfin voilà il y
avait un très beau un très beau tout est
beau très beau plateau
donc c'est de bon augure mais attention
faut pas oublier que au jeu de aux jeux
de rio nos français était aussi le
favori un joris joris tongres en demi
finale et ils sont tous tombés équipe
je me souviens voilà que le jury salue
quand valentino également suite à la
finale donc c est ben voilà et pourtant
ils étaient favoris devait ramener des
médailles et le bmx est revenu la queue
entre les jambes
mais un guide ont alors vu le succès
rencontré une nouvelle manche de coupe
du monde devrait être organisée à
l'année prochaine à saint quentin en
yvelines les aurons du coup un an pour
peaufiner leur stratégie un gentil alors
que spectateur ne sont pas laissé un
gros succès les spectateurs c'est un
gros succès au niveau de la cage a
retenti non non on continue par du
baseball les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux on peut être écrit l'une des
plus belles pages de leur histoire les
unit montant réussi à terminer troisième
de la coupe d'europe le dimanche 9 juin
en république tchèque
une performance unique depuis la
création du club est forcément
l'entraîneur l'équipe était très
satisfait de la performance de ses
joueurs on écoute on road of summer très
bons résultats
ces deux fruits de tous les efforts qui
ont été faits au long de ces dernières
années au club c'est tout d'abord une
belle image pour monter mais cette
troisième place pour les clubs et aussi
c'est un résultat nécessaire pour la
france parce qu'on conserve la france en
coupe d'europe dès donc la france pourra
participer en europe mais l'année
prochaine par une fois en championnat
les cougars de monti le bretonneux sont
en playoffs ils ont terminé deuxièmes de
leur poule avec un bilan de 13 victoires
et 7 défaites
ils sont maintenant dans un mini
championnat à six équipes en playoffs
ils doivent maintenant faire un sans
faute pour se qualifier pour la finale
la question sur ce thème est ce que
cette performance peut les booster
jusqu'à la fin de la saison en sachant
qu'il doit faire un sans-faute caisse ou
presque oui vous êtes d'accord
véronique ça peut coller postale que les
booster vous pensez pas qu'ils ont en
plus un petit peu d'énergie
non pas du tout à partir de la victoire
l'énergie c'est d'énergie positive c'est
d'énergie qui va décupler encore
l'énergie derrière non c'est au
contraire ils partent avec un mental
fort physiquement confiants en eux et
puis non
c'est que du positif que du positif oui
cause du positif parce que je pense que
effectivement des performances comme
celle là permettent aussi aux joueurs de
se transcender et d'avoir un regard
d'énergie au vue des compétitions à
venir et surtout face à des performances
comme ça on va bénéficier forcément d'un
d'un support
supplémentaires ce soit financier ou
même au niveau des supporters enfin bon
voilà je pense qu'arriver la france de
rester en coupe d'europe l'année
prochaine
gamin donc il va y avoir un soutien je
pense derrière eux qui si toutefois il y
avait un épuisement le comblera l'homme
d'autres pointures enfin moi je pense
une seule chose c'est que quand on fait
des sports alors mineure pour nous en
france que dans aux etats unis c'est ça
fait partie des sports majeurs mais
quand on fait un sport mineur pour
pouvoir faire parler de soi il faut
briller au plus haut niveau possible
donc ça fait quand même des années
qu'ils ont des très bons résultats au
niveau du championnat de france
ils sont très régulièrement récompensées
ben voilà maintenant faut aller taper
taper au niveau européen s'ils en ont
les possibilités les capacités pour
pouvoir faire parler d'eux pour pouvoir
gravir des échelons et l'expérience qui
vont emmagasiner sur une coupe d'europe
va leur permettre de deux encore brillé
plus facilement en championnat et selon
le coach il aurait pu faire mieux plus à
l'est en finale peut être remporter la
première ou la deuxième place est bien
la seule chose c'est que ben aleya ils
peuvent toujours faire appel à nous on
n'est pas champion eh ben photo qu'on
attend qu'on n'a pas gagné voilà on peut
toujours progresser on peut toujours
faire mieux et attention il j'ai revu
des messages sur facebook a pas très
longtemps de d'expérience que j'ai pu
avoir ce qu'on est en pleine période de
championnat de france pour pour moi et
c'est vrai que le plus dur c'est pas de
monter sur la première marche c'est d'y
rester
voilà et sa g 20 ne faut pas faut pas
oublier les ce type de déconvenue par la
suite mais la voilà ils sont en phase de
progression
il continue de grossir continue
d'emmagasiner des belles expériences et
du très haut niveau
continuez les gars allez-y faites vous
plaisir et ramenez nous ramenez la coupe
à la maison
treize victoires sept défaites depuis le
début de la saison
et s'ils n'ont pas un petit peu de
puiser quand même un petit peu de gens
dans leurs réservoirs avant d'avoir de
quoi
deux emplois physique ou du mental et du
physique langue parce qu'une saison une
saison c'est qu'un bon c'est pas sympa
et tout le monde 9 effet le même nombre
de matches on peut être donné comme
objectif la coupe d'europe alors ça par
contre on ne sait pas l'objectif du club
c'était le championnat on ne connaît pas
les causes de cette année c'est la coupe
d'europe donc il finissait 3e ils
veulent bien sûr terminer le plus haut
possible en championnat qui lui seront
qualifiés pour la coupe d'europe l'année
prochaine
mais ce qui est normal maintenant il
allège sont confrontés à ce qui se fait
de mieux en europe et dans leur
discipline
donc forcément ils vont ils vont ils
vont monter d'un cran au niveau au
niveau national donc là pour gagner leur
prochain match mais ça ils visualisent
ont ils ont en main un positif de 2 2 2
2 je sais pourquoi j'ai compris mais en
fait ce qui se passe et sa voile à vous
de nous le dire
ils ont ils sont en ballotage compliqué
pour pouvoir aller finir très bien sûr
mais justement pour pouvoir refaire la
coupe d'europe l'année prochaine ça va
les aider ça va les motiver qui va cela
va les motiver à aller chercher toutes
ces vidéos du tout au contraire
contraire du vivre ils ont dû vivre un
truc génial à voir quand même de
damoclès qui n'ont pas devoir y lisons
pas de marge d'erreur alors ça c'est
compliqué quand même donc qu'ils vont
ils vont peut-être un petit peu un petit
peut être fébrile parce que lorsqu'on
n'a pas de possibilité de marge de
manoeuvre
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais là
allez on leur souhaite on leur souhaite
d'y arriver est d'être qualifié pour la
prochaine ce sera le mot de la fin sur
cette thématique on passe maintenant
notre page des bas dans cette page débat
nous allons parler d'une école le ms
business school une école de commerce
sur les métiers du sport vient de
s'ouvrir à guyancourt
à partir de septembre prochain proposera
des études post bac pour diriger les
étudiants vers les différents secteurs
du sport comme le management le
marketing la communication et
l'événementiel et le digital on écoute
le responsable de l'école au micro de tv
78 on s'est posé la question moi même
issu du monde du sport de l'univers du
sport on s'est posé la question qu'est
ce qui était fait autour de l'éducation
de ce qu'on pouvait proposer en termes
de métiers autour de 2 des sports et du
coup ben on a travaillé sur ce projet
d'étude de marché en études de marché
on s'est aperçu qu'en france il existait
très peu d'écoles spécialisées dans dans
les métiers du sport business
rien à voir avec ce tableau en forme des
éducateurs ou
sur notre là on est vraiment en école de
commerce qu'essayer dans le monde dans
l'univers du sport business
il ya seulement quatre écoles de ce type
en ile de france la question sur ce
thème êtes vous convaincu par cette
école oui ou non
où voter non pour véronique chaplin ou a
fait un petit duel avec avec jean
véronique hivon commencer vous n'êtes
pas convaincu j'suis pas qu'on m'accuse
je demande à voir
je suis pas convaincu aujourd'hui parce
que le sport business ya c'est le sport
est maintenant à support tout le monde
de travailler dans le sport de plus en
plus etc
c'est bien le projet est bien maintenant
je te demande à avoir l'opérationnel et
concrètement le contenu et vers quoi
s'attend des choses vraiment concrète
est ce que les encadrants sont des vrais
professionnels
est-ce que c'est pas seulement d'un
cadre en extérieur oui juste en espérant
que ce sera soit pas que de la
récupération business et que l'objectif
ait les moyens me sont réellement poussé
pas noir dans les métiers du sport donc
avec grand plaisir je suivrai de près
jeudi la base du bémol je peux encore
convaincu parce que il ya des
expériences que j'ai pu connaître qui
sont pas toujours positives mais je suis
ravi que cette école ce monde et je leur
ferai toujours donne tout mon soutien et
je suivrai ça de près
j'en mets moi attention non moi évoluer
par véronique wi lan mais oui mais c'est
toujours mais j'écoute toujours avec un
tas de choses que l'on dit toujours très
intéressant moi je fais je suis
convaincu bon même si c'est quand même
c'est quand même une école un peu
élitiste parce que c'est quand 8000
euros l'année c'est ça dont 1000 euros
par an environ sur les trois premières
années et la cinquième année coûte 9000
euros
il ya une possibilité de faire une
alternance oui pour enfin donc bon on ne
sait pas c'est pas n'importe qui peut
aller là déjà après dans le monde du
sport actuel il est certain que si au
niveau de tout ce qui est à jeun tout ce
qui est directeur marketing tout ce qui
est elle plus encadré ce parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
sauvage
on a un petit peu dire six mois demain
où nous on peut se monter un jeune
joueur comme ça du jour au lendemain tu
as cannes et hop je le fais vive la même
un diplôme le diplôme je connais les
agents il aurait diplôme utilisons le
bepc
c'est ce qu'a dit peu mais là c'est sûr
alors c'est sûr dans le football moi je
bois les agents je suis impatient de
bepc le certificat d'études maternelle
non non il n'y a rien pour l'instant
c'est pas trop contrôlé alors si c'est
quoi le la à la fin on délivre
un diplôme qui est reconnue après et que
qui est demandée pour encadrer des
professionnels dans différentes
disciplines
parce que les professionnels on entend
de plus en plus besoin de cet
encadrement parce qu'on voit notamment
on parle du football c'est vrai mais
parce que c'est un le football c'est le
sport numéro un ici et et qu' il n'y a
pas il ya le football à nantes école non
non non non non mais non mais je parle
du football parce que c'est celui que
j'ai parlé de plus de lui et que c'est à
travers ce sport en france où on voit
des salaires mirobolants avec des gens
qui qui perdent qui perdent la tête
complètement et qui dérivent
complètement
donc c'est vrai que si c'est pour former
des gens pour encadrer sérieusement ces
sportifs là moi je dis oui je suis dit
oui a su à 100% après jeu là où je
rejoins véronique c'est wait and see vos
seins voyons un petit peu ce qu'ils vont
en sortir
est ce que c'est vraiment quelque chose
de sérieux avec des un cadre sérieux des
intervenants sérieux et un résultat
sérieux ou est-ce que c'est simplement
de la récupération déjà business pour
eux et après on verra pour les autres de
la jatte a en tout cas les métiers du
sport représente 6 % de croissance par
an dans le commerce
c'est pour ça que je vous dis on en a
besoin
raul qui vous a convaincu alors vous
étiez plus d'accord avec jean moi je
pense que c'est une bonne démarche
d'abord 8000 euros l'année
c'est cher ça c'est sûr malheureusement
je ne connais pas beaucoup de l'école de
commerce il soit en dessous de ce prix
là est versée dans les prix du marché
voilà c'est ce que nous dit donc c'est
une école de commerce communauté sait
jamais si jamais gratuit d'aller étudier
malheureusement sauf à la fac
par contre voilà sauf que je moi je
valide la démarche parce
qu'effectivement elle doit répondre à
une certaine frustration on est on est
beaucoup être passionné du sport
malheureusement on est très peu à
pouvoir faire carrière en tant que
sportif alors il ya déjà des brèches
dans lesquelles on peut on peut
s'introduire le journalisme la médecine
aussi médecin du sport
mais effectivement ça va permettre
peut-être de structurer un peu le cursus
des personnes qui voudront apporte
approché le sport d'une d'une autre
manière et de pouvoir gagner leur vie
par ce biais ça c'est la première chose
est le deuxième argument qui
confortement propose c'est que je pense
que le sport a besoin de businessman
effectivement il ya un sale aspects de
l'argent dans le sport je le reconnais
corruption et autres mais je pense que
le sport et les sportifs ont beau jeu en
besoin de businessman d'abord pour la
gestion de leur carrière
ensuite parfois même pour leur
reconversion et
et parce que il ya certains sportifs et
je prends l'exemple de mon métier à
savoir l'équitation
il est impossible en tant que sportif de
haut niveau de vivre de ses résultats en
compétition la plupart des cavaliers
sont obligés de tenir des boutiques et
j'imagine que c'est pareil dans d'autres
sports donc voila nous de jouer au pmu
mais en tous les cas je crois que la
proche la prose business du sport et est
indispensable pour que pour que voilà le
sport continue à rayonner et soient
véhiculés par des gens sensés et former
les réglementations je vais juste parler
de ça c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
réglementations sont de plus en plus
compliqué les contrats le sont aussi de
plus en plus il faut des vrais
professionnels pour pouvoir les établir
et pour pouvoir les lire et les
comprendre
donc pour moi c'est normal qu'il y ait
des écoles pour pouvoir former des gens
à l étude tout à l'heure tu disais
d'encadrement moi je vais plutôt pâle et
d'accompagnement parce que je pense
qu'un agent de joueur il n'est pas là
pour il n'est pas là pour l'encadrer il
est plus là pour l'accompagner dans ses
choix dans ses relais dans les
propositions qui va y avoir donc et ça
peut être plus je trouve que le mot
encadrement c'est un peu basse et ouais
c'est l'école s'est scellé le cadre de
la maison c'est donc le cadre familial
là là quand on a un agent il est pas là
pour il est pas là pour jouer le rôle
des parents il n'est plus là pour alors
sauf si apple parents et parce que dans
certains sports voilà il ya il s'est
promené ses pneumatiques ont besoin
d'investisseurs aussi look si on en
trouve justement forme des personnes à
faire le lien entre les gens qui sont
partants pour générer des fonds et les
acteurs sportifs ça sera bénéfique pour
le sport je pense tout à l'heure on se
sert du sport pour faire du qualitatif
mais aujourd'hui on a énormément de mal
à financer le sport principalement donc
du coup c'est vrai que c'est bien
d'utiliser mais c'est vrai que ça serait
bien de le financer
ce serait même des financiers quand on
voit que nos sportifs qui participent
aux jeux olympiques il y en a une grande
majorité qui vivent en deçà du seuil de
pauvreté
c'est quand même c'est quand même fou
quoi ils vont nous représenter sur des
sur deux sur des événements et on est
issu le trafic hier 2 mais derrière faut
bien voir la victime zoo qu'ils ont au
quotidien quoi donc des relais ils
attendirent sûr bien sûr il faut des
entreprises des deux côtés parce que
c'est très utile pour les entreprises
d'avoir l'habitude de sportifs même
ponctuellement
moi je pense que voilà toutes les
qualités la discipline le sens de
l'effort et c est très utile transposé
dans l'entreprise
tu es là il ya vraiment des liens à
faire et si cette école pas dans ce sens
là bas je dis bonus une vingtaine
d'heures de cours par semaine environ
véronique eu 20 heures oui c'est bien
non c'est bien je suppose que vous
très bien en tout cas si vous voulez
découvrir cette école des portes
ouvertes sont organisées tous les
samedis jusqu'à la fin du mois de
juillet boulevard vauban à lui en
courant passe maintenant à notre page
découverte dans notre page découverte
nous allons parler d'un sport peu connu
du grand public le kayak-polo une
journée du championnat régional de la
discipline se tenait le dimanche 7 juin
sur l'île de loisirs de 50 en ligne ce
sport mélange à la fois le handball le
water polo il se pratique sur l'eau
présentation ce sport par des licenciés
c'est du kayak alors faut savoir faire
du bateau et après dès qu'on prend la
balle en main on oublie le bateau donc
ce n'est pas bon en kayak à la base on
n'avait pas très bien à manoeuvrer et
ensuite après c'est un véritable sport
collectif
on est obligé de mettre en place des
tactiques des techniques pour pour pour
jouer comme dans tous les sports
collectifs de petits terrains pour
savoir où on est où son nouveau
coéquipier savoir où on va surtout pour
aller vers le but et marqué les gens qui
sont plutôt attirés c'est les familles
les amis ont à dire les gens qui passent
parce que ils sont jamais vu cette
activité à la question sur ce thème
est ce que c'est une discipline à tester
oui ou non non c'est parce que ça tester
pas forcément pour nous les surveillons
déjà testé puisque c'est une discipline
une discipline un opus qui est assez
complète parce que le kayak au niveau
musculaire c'est évident c'est assez
complet et puis et puis après il ya
quand même le sport collectif
ils l'ont dit ça rejoint le le handball
le volley donc bien sûr ça peut être
très intéressant
quelques années en arrière j'aurais
peut-être voulu le tester mais là je
crois que là je pourrai pas il me ferait
trop de bras pour avancer voilà le spa
sida
le sous l'eau peut-être qu on leur a pas
posé la question
véronique oui ludique fun à faire en
famille entre amis que ses terres à
découvrir mois à fond je vais y aller au
bout
bah oui moi je ne vous cache pas que la
plupart des sports qui sont proposés
pour cette rubrique en général on me
laisse assez dubitatif mais ça l'a
atteint c'est la rubrique découvert un
seul but hâtif réseau en un seul mauvais
mais celle-là bon parce que parce que
la leyre de solliciter physiquement les
pratiquants donc déjà pour moi c'est la
condition sine qua none pour que ce soit
un sport et qu'en plus elle implique
qu'il faut coordonner plusieurs choses à
la fois bon bah je valide donc en tout
cas je vais vous donner quelques
quelques règles à un kayak polo le kayak
polo se joue à cinq contre cinq sur
l'eau un match se divise en deux mi
temps de dix minutes un plan d'eau calme
délimité de 35 mètres sur 20 mètres en
extérieur ou en piscine
le ballon peut être relancer à la main
ou projetés à l'aide de la pagaie c'est
à sellette mais parce que c'était un
temps d'attac de seulement une minute
si on n'arrive pas à tirer au bout d'une
minute il faut rendre la balle au camp
adverse
les accidents et les grilles c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont protégés
ah bah oui parce que là si l'asse c'est
bien yann déjà fait déjà faits et avait
déjà fait pas tout simplement un stage
d'été kayak sur le plan d'eau de
carcans-maubuisson et voilà et donc que
ben quand vous êtes un petit une petite
dizaine à on met un ballon au milieu de
l'eau et puis voilà quoi on essaye de
quelques ballons tout simplement voilà
on n'avait pas de but mais voilà une
petite passe à dix donc donc déjà fait
ce type de ce type de jeu et parce que
voilà ça reste ça reste un jeu et là où
je te revois en effet c'est un peu
physique quand on n'a pas l'habitude de
travailler ses bras mais justement
comment on fait pour gérer un match
bah on est cramé on y travaille on est
cramé au bout de 2 minutes et puis après
il ya un truc qui s'appelle le second
souffle qui fait que vous tapez un peu
moins dedans mais qui permet de pouvoir
on est un peu d'endurance et de
travailler sur l'endurance tout
simplement et puis et puis voilà donc
vous jouez pendant une demi heure mais
c'est vrai que quand vous avez fini la
séance
ben le lendemain vous savez ce que vous
avez fait la veille quand le verbe pas
kitsch dans les placards midi le
beaucoup de blessures ça va être un
sport où il devrait y avoir une entente
de blessures que c'est bien là je vous
d'une souris mais je ne dis pas que des
bêtises
le petit le coup de paniers sur la main
quand il rentre vicieux non mais
derrière la tête parce qu'il est passé
et même pas la mer est calé différence
avec le polo classic
non mais lors de ce que je vois là ça
ressemble beaucoup plus haut s'ils ont
raison les disciplines équestres au
horse ball
c'est pas du polo du tout la non pas du
tout non mais je pense qu'ils ont dit
paulo parce que le fait souvent quand là
bas le sport aquatique avec la balle
comme le water-polo
ils ont dit paulo mais effectivement il
ya les mêmes il ya les mêmes services
locaux horse ball
mais non non non le polo c'est ça
ressemble plus au clic est alors c'est
unis sont quand même assez ancienne 1 le
kayak et bâle
le cannibale à la base du kayak-polo
ensuite se pratiquait déjà dans les
années trente premiers championnats du
monde en 1994 en grande bretagne en 1983
première compétition nationale en france
et aujourd'hui d'oreiller il devrait y
avoir environ 10000 pratiquants en
france de renault me suis très surpris
de voir ou revoir
ne laissez pas du tout je découvre
fais-tu le butô appelé à ce qu'elle
écouterait vous n'écoutez pas qu'est ce
que tu fais ce que tu penses de ce que
j'ai dit jean le souffle ou en classant
le disais en début d'émission ses dix
mille amateurs de ce sport c'était pas
mal pour mais il en schiste s'est lui
dit que le pratiquer en as assez ludique
c'est fascinant mais bon boulot s'est
passé water-polo c'est pour le water
polo t elle
oui mais la kayak polo le mot paulo
c'est pour le water polo c'est pas pour
le sweat sais pas c'est pas pourquoi pas
posé la question bah oui mais forcément
forcément c'est juste un stage de deux
jours quand même dans un an ce dans ce
sport là mais c'est aimer mais c'est moi
je suis 100% pour ça c'est très bien
c'est lui dit que c'est un bus je
maintiens et le poiré norman de blessés
ce qui est assez facile à mettre en
place des plans d'eau plat calme il y en
a quand même beaucoup
un peu partout voilà donc ces appareils
il faut dit il faut des kayaks donc là
c'est moins
on a tous on a moins dans les garages
mais met donc pour moi voilà c'est vrai
que c'est des sports qui sont qui sont
faciles à facile à appréhender quoi vous
pourriez tester gens alors vous trouvez
pas que c'est au sport dans harry potter
à locaux dietsch là au coup du cheval
arabe
bon je le fais juste à côté je le fais
je le fais c'est noté en tout cas riche
c'est fait c'est la fin de cette
émission va terminer comme d'habitude
par une citation aujourd'hui focus sur
une citation de l'ancien joueur de
manchester united eric cantona un
artiste c'est celui qui a le don
d'éclairer une chambre noire je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78 c'est du kayak
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]